it was a day marred by controversy
guests were told to arrive early in the
morning only to discover delayed to the
inauguration ceremony of President
ostrov honey
while they waited u.s. envoy's Alma
Holland Zod was trying to bridge the
political rift between honey and his
rival Abdullah Abdullah by mid-afternoon
the ceremony to start any second term
was finally underway with the US envoy
and other Aven and foreign officials in
the audience Ronnie took his oath of
office promising to uphold the
Constitution and bring security
well this ceremony's happening here is
another presidential inauguration
unfolding not very far from where we are
that's the one and he says that he is
the winner and the legitimate President
of Afghanistan taking the same oath his
rival did Abdullah rejects the result of
the presidential election in September
and is calling for a rerun by Mohammed
or him if I accept the fraud to happen
during the election and it would be
witnessing the end of democracy it's not
in favor of the country we will form a
government according to the demands and
need to the people we will bring change
after the ceremony was more populous no
officials of foreign delegations here
down with the enemy of Abdullah his
supporters chanted but it was also a day
marred by violence
Seema while the two men were being sworn
in and jumped at several rockets were
fired at the presidential compound
landing very close to where Hani was
giving a speech the president remained
at the podium defiantly opening his
shirt to show he wasn't wearing any
protection
I shall claim responsibility for the
rocket attack monday was a public
holiday for avalance the streets of
Kabul were unusually empty what was
supposed to be the start of a new
chapter turned out to be a day when
political rivalry toured the country
apart a little more horrible Hamad Al
Jazeera Kabul